[Music]
yes thank you very much for helping us
out here I'm a big fan of yours I am I
saw a Green Mile three times which one
were you
I see but you gotta be excited you
nominated for Best Supporting Actor and
sending next me we look like a semicolon
and yeah okay and then your Awards
coming up in a couple hours there's got
to be a big thrill point well this whole
night is up to it's especially an honor
to be here with someone who makes me
laugh so hard for so long thank you very
much
I ain't telling about you
I'm talking about birth right get and
woody
you know the guys from Toy Story 2 and
you don't play at all but this is the
real thing what's okay if you're gonna
present just now presenting our next
award our Buzz Lightyear and we you see
what happens when you got the magic I
see you sleep
I can also see my movie was so long
right
[Applause]
it's just a security precaution woody
I've been receiving some questionable
phone calls oh it's okay photos is on
the list
yeah over here buzz look at you this is
the Oscars it's supposed to be formal
well I would explain all the Penguins
then got it will you two dummies hurry
it up I want to see the interpretive
dance pay extra to sitting at winneth
Paltrow hello best animated short film
our hub drum Peter peak my grandmother I
earned the Kings curse torille Kovac the
old man in the sea Alexander Petrov
three misses Paul Driessen when the day
breaks windy till be an Amanda forbus
and the Oscar goes to what invert the
envelope but I don't have it I owe
and the Oscar goes to the old man in the
sea
[Applause]
weboost Academy Award for Russian born
Alexander
petrovin his third nomination
his animation technique for this film
involves painting each frame on glass
plates with his fingers
[Music]
[Music]
sorry I don't speak English not thank
you very much I very proud very happy
sense of - - member of Academy for your
choice a spicy go back show the seed
onion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]